happily we all have at least one thing
in common we were all once children we
grew out of it probably the worst thing
that ever happened to us certainly the
most traumatic but I think that we can
all find our way back into that space in
fact I think that we all every now and
then have that guilty pleasure of
thinking like a child which we do our
best not to mention in in public not to
give too much credence to but I think
that we can give credence to that even
if we don't want to admit it necessarily
to our superiors or some of our friends
probably would think twice about
associating with us if they knew that we
were as naive as we really are
but we can still for our own sake the
back of our mind ask those sorts of
questions and let them play out we can
fully develop them and even if it's only
in our own mind that we are fully
developing them that process can take us
to something that is more concrete
something that is more actionable in a
an adult responsible world that we don't
really need to say we came to it through
that naive question we only have to then
take up where it got us and make use of
that in terms of solving the problems
within our lives whether they be
personal or whether they be at the level
of making the most of the world in which
we work several years ago I got to be
very interested in honeybees and the
extraordinary talent they have for
dancing they're better dancers than us
they've been doing it a lot longer and
they certainly seem to have dance as
their culture
to a greater extent than probably any
other species so I got to thinking about
whether there was a way to work with
honeybees collaboratively making use of
their dance in a way that would
choreograph it as we do amongst
ourselves for human audiences the way in
which they dance is determined by where
flowers are to be found and that
information can be used as a way of
marking a dance that they might be able
to perform so what I did was I studied
extensively the language of bees the
language by which they indicate to
others where flowers are to be found
so that others can then to go and find
those flowers and in the process of
pollinating them bring back more nectar
or more pollen for the hive and having
decided on some basic geometric
arrangements for my dance that I was
going to provide for the beads I worked
out where hives were in the city of San
Francisco relative to places that I
might plant flowers and then mapped out
specifically where the flowers should be
planted as a way of choreographing
of marking in their own language
according to their own way of moving
what sorts of moves might follow others
in a way that aesthetically speaking to
me at least seemed like it might appeal
to them all of this was done with total
freedom as far as the bees were
concerned to follow by suggestions or
not and also without any sort of
obligation to perform for us that is to
say that I mapped it out and then
working with some collaborators went and
planted the flowers and I made a map
which was available for human audiences
if they were interested in seeing what
the bees were up to but there were no
cameras in the hives there was no way in
which we would be able to
watch what they were doing it wasn't
some sort of a minstrel show it wasn't
some sort of a performance for us it was
a performance that was offered to the
bees for their own amusement for their
own interest their own edification such
that then they might find the aesthetic
in their dance and move beyond simply
using dance in a utilitarian way for
finding where flowers were - making that
an integral part of their culture at the
level of art in our culture I often
start any project by asking a naive
question so naive that most likely you
ask these sorts of questions when you
were a child but at a certain age you
learned that these were not appropriate
or even if you ask them to yourself you
never really followed through to try to
see what would happen if you were to do
something that was kind of patently
absurd in the case of the honeybee
ballet I had the question of whether I
could choreograph a ballet for another
species communicating across species in
a way that might facilitate a greater
deeper relationship between us
especially at a time where colonnaded
collapse disorder was effectively
through our use of pesticides destroying
their habitat was there a way in which
we could find some sort of a common
ground and dance is such an essential
part of what we do as humans that I
thought that perhaps I could offer that
to the bees as something that they could
participate in as well so asking that
question could i choreograph a ballet
for another species for honeybees I
don't know any of them I've never talked
to them I know only about them as much
as I've ever read but realizing that
their language is incredibly
sophisticated arguably as sophistic
his hours according to their culture
according to their needs
that I could find that common ground and
once I had figured out the basic way in
which to try to communicate with them
using their own language using using
flowers I realized that there was a way
in which I could pursue this rather
naive question not for the sake of
reaching an answer a solution that would
resolve this in some definitive way but
rather as a way of continuing my
exploration bringing others into it as
well that we could continue to think
about what sort of relationship we have
with other species how our culture and
theirs have commonalities because we all
come from the same place and we all need
to get to the same place so how do we do
that
the bigger question of how we live
within a world that is as complex as
ours in harmony with other species is
one that gets addressed through this
much smaller more naive question of
asking what would it mean what would it
take to choreograph a ballet for
honeybees
you